نعم اهلا بك انا معكم وكما تشاهدون الان
نعم الان كما تشاهدون وصلت الان في هذه
اللحظه سفينه جلاله الملك ينبع وهي
السفينه تقول على متنها 199 شخص من ضمن او
من 14 جنسيه مختلفه من ضمنهم عشره
السعوديين وجنسيات مختلفه امريكيه
وايطاليه وجنسيات عربيه وجنسيات مختلفه
الان حطت رحالها على متلها 199 شخص تم
اجلائهم من ميناء السودان من السودان بعد
ان تم اجلائهم برا من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم ها هي الان تحط رحالها بعد رحله
استغرقت قرابه 12 الساعه نتحدث نتحدث انه
هنالك جنسيات متعدده على سبيل المثال
الجنسيه الامريكيه شخصين وجنسيه الهولنديه
ثلاثه اشخاص وكذلك من بريطانيا خمسه اشخاص
ومن تركيا شخصين ومن لبنان 45 شخص ومن
سوريا 15 شخص ومن السعوديه عشر اشخاص
والرقم الا هو من ليبيا بعدد 104 اشخاص
نتحدث عن جهود كبيره وتنسيقات كبرى تعمل
عليها الحكومه السعوديه مع كافه الاطراف
هنالك في السودان لاجلاء رعاياها وكذلك
اجلال بعض الطلبات التي استقبلتها السفاره
السعوديه في الخرطوم من قبل الرعايه نتحدث
على دول مختلفه والمتوقع ان يصل اعداد
الرعايه الى اكثر من 2000 شخص من جنسيات
مختلفه على علاماتنا هذه السفينه كما
نشاهد الان ها هم الرعايه وهذه السفينه
الضخمه التي تقول 199 الشخص نتحدث من خلال
اليومين الماضيين اكثر من 157 شخص تم
اجلائهم من ميناء بورد سودان نتحدث انه من
ضمن 91 سعودي وسته وستين شخص اجنبي من
جنسيات عربيه وخليجيه واوروبيه اذا تحدثنا
عن فيما يتعلق بعمليات الاجلاء بشكل عام
وصلت اليوم في تمام الساعه الخامسه عصرا
طائره اجلاء كوريه قادمه من مطار برج
سودان وصولا الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه جده وعلى متنها 39 شخصيه دبلوماسيه
كوريه بمقدمتهم القنصل او السفير الكوري
هنالك في الخرطوم لا تزال عمليات الاجلاء
الياء الرعايه بمختلف جنسياتهم مستمره على
مدار الساعه من قبل القوات البحريه
السعوديه وكذلك اذا تحدثنا من المتوقع من
خلال الساعات القادمه ان تكون هنالك رحله
جويه سوف تصل الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه حتى هذه اللحظه لم تتاكد لكنه
متوقع وصولها خلال الساعات القادمه كما
نشاهد هذه السفينه الضخمه وهي السفينه
جلاله الملك ينبوع تحمل على متنها كما
ذكرنا قبل قليل 199 شخص من اربعه عشر
جنسيه مختلفه قبل قليل سوف يكون في
استقبالهم قناهصلهم نتحدث على القناص
الموجوده بجده 14 قنصليه متواجده من خلال
القناصل ومناديبس السفارات في جده وفي
السعوديه بشكل عام وصلوا الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده لاستقبال رعاياهم سوف
يتم تقديم كافه الخدمات اللوجست
الطبيه والاعاشيه لهؤلاء الرعايه بعد
نزولهم من هذه السفينه الضخمه نتحدث سوف
يتم استقبالهم انهاء اجراءات السفر الخاصه
به من قبل المديريه العامه للجوازات وكذلك
اداره الجمارك سوف سوف يتم استقبالهم
التاكد من سلامتهم وصحتهم ومن ثم انهاء
كافه الاجراءات المتعلقه برعايه الواقعين
او علامه هذه السفينه نشاهد الان بعض
اللقطات لبعض الرعايه الان كما يظهر
امامكم هم يعني بطبيعه الحال يعني مشاعر
مختلفه يشعرون بها وتحديدا يعني يشعرون
بالامان بعد وصولهم الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بجده بعد الاوضاع الماساويه التي
تعيشها السودان نتحدث فوضى كبيره كان
يعيشها اهالي السودان وكذلك كافه الرعايه
المقيمين في السودان اليوم السعوديه تعمل
على استقبال كافه الطلبات والموافقه على
بعضها من خلال نقلهم واجلائهم ضرا من
الخرطوم
مدينه بورتسودان ومن ثم بحرا الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه بجده عبر القوات
البحريه السعوديه لا تزال عمليات الاجلاء
مستمره على مدار الساعه من المتوقع ان تصل
كذلك رحلات يوم غد ايضا ذكر السفير
السعودي في الخرطوم من السفاره السعوديه
تعمل استقبال بعض الطلبات واتمام عمليه
وتنسيق عمليات اجلائهم عبر السفن البحريه
العسكريه السعوديه كما نشاهد يلوحون
بايديهم وهم بطبيعه الحال يعني يشعرون
بمشاعر الفرح والامان والسعاده بعد وصولهم
الى بر الامان هنا في مدينه جده بعد
الفوضى والماساويات الكبيره التي يعيشها
المجتمع السوداني وكذلك كافه الرعايه
العاملين هنالك نتحدث على جنسيات مختلفه
اكثر من 14 جنسيه تعاملت معها اليوم على
متن هذه السفينه ايضا متوقع تتنوع
الجنسيات كذلك خلال الايام القادمه واكدت
السفاره السعوديه في الخرطوم ان عمليات
الاجلاء على مدار الساعه بالتنسيق معدات
الخارجيه السعوديه وما حكومات الرعايه
هؤلاء البلدان ايضا دقائق معدوده وسوف
ترسو هذه السفينه على على ميناء او الرصيف
الخاص بقاعه الملك فيصل البحريه سيتم
استقباله من قبل اداره الجمارك ومن قبل
مديريه العامه
للجوازات سوف يتم استقبالهم وانهاء
اجراءاتهم ومن ثم بعد ذلك سوف يتم اكمال
عمليه نقلهم الى مساكن خاصه بهم في جده
وفرتها الحكومه السعوديه وانها وتقديم
كافه الخدمات اللوجستيه الخاصه بهؤلاء
الرعايه نؤكد انه السفر السعوديه في
الخرطوم وزاره الخارجيه الحكومه السعوديه
والقياده السعوديه تعمل على استقبال
الطلبات والموافقه على بعضها لنقلهم لنقل
الرعايه الى مدينه جده عبر ميناء السودان
اعداد كبيره تجاوزت الالفين شخص تم نقلهم
بحرا وجوا متوقعا تستاد الاعداد خلال
اليومين القادمه وتزال عم نجلاء مستمره
كما نشاهد الان الجميع على متن هذه
السفينه ينتظرون بكل شوق وحب ان يصلوا او
ينزلوا الى هذا المرسى او هذا الرصيف
البحري لاستقبالهم من قبل اهاليهم ومن قبل
القناصل الخاصه ببلدانهم الجنسيات مختلفه
كما تحدثنا 14 شخص 14 جنسيه مختلفه سوف
يتم استقباله من قبل قناصل وكذلك عائلاتهم
سوف يتم التاكد من سلامتهم وصحتهم وانهاء
كافه اجراءات السفر في المده لا تتجاوز
الساعه الواحده لا سيما ان كافه الدوائر
الحكوميه المتعلقه بانهاء اجراءات السفر
هي متواجده هنا للتسهيل على على الرعايه
وانهاء اجراءاته في اقرب وقت ممكن سوف يتم
الذهاب بهم الى اربعه فنادق في جده تم
تخصيصها هذه الرعايه طوال اليومين
الماضيين وكذلك 199 شخص سوف يتم ايضا نقله
من الفنادق لاخذ الاستراحه وتاكل من
سلامتهم وصحتهم ومن ثم انهاء اجراءات
السفر الخاصه ببلدانهم لمتابعتي المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات